Relecteur: Hélène Vernet
Salut tout le monde, moi c'est Flo,
on m'appelle « l'artiste de l'invisible ».
Je vois des têtes loucher
en mode « le type va disparaître »
ou « il a l’habitude d’être en retard ».
Non, ce n'est pas ça,
et il n’y a pas que moi.
Dans le milieu du cinéma,
on nous appelle parfois,
nous, spécialistes en effets spéciaux,
les « artistes de l'invisible ».
Pourquoi ?
Eh bien, c'est parce que si notre travail
est bien fait, il ne se voit pas.
Alors, c’est clair que quand on incruste
des monstres partout à l’image,
ça se voit, et clairement, c’est le but.
Mais si le trucage est de qualité,
le spectateur ne passe pas
son temps à se dire :
« Tiens, Godzilla, Pikachu,
on les a ajoutés. »
Non, ils sont là,
ils prennent part à l’histoire,
et ils font leur vie
de monstre ou de Pokemon.
Dans le milieu, on appelle ça
une « intégration d’image de synthèse ».
Comment ça marche pour réaliser une
bonne intégration d’image de synthèse ?
Eh bien, je dirais qu’il y a deux choses.
Dans un premier temps,
il y a la technique et le savoir-faire
que j’inscrirais
dans un processus créatif.
Et de l’autre côté, il y a l’expérience.
Bien sûr, il y a aussi d’autres facteurs,
mais aujourd’hui j’aimerais vous parler
de mon processus créatif,
et surtout vous dire ce que
représente pour moi, aujourd'hui,
avoir de l'expérience.
Au début, je pensais
que pour réussir cette alchimie
qui permet d’intégrer des images
de synthèse dans une image réelle,
il suffisait d’attraper le gros
guide des effets spéciaux
d'ouvrir mon logiciel clic-clic,
et puis alors ça me dit…
page 45 « les gros monstres »,
pour une bonne intégration,
suivez les étapes suivantes…
Je pensais aussi que
l’expérience était quantifiable
au nombre de trucs et astuces
que tu connaissais,
que tu avais dans ta boîte à outils.
Mais en fait, ça ne marche
pas vraiment comme ça.
Bien sûr, on a des techniques établies
qui ont fait leurs preuves avec le temps.
Par exemple, on sait retirer
les fonds verts des fonds bleus,
on peut créer des images de synthèse
réalistes avec une animation plausible,
on suit les règles de la physique pour
recréer des explosions et des fluides.
Malgré tout ça, à chaque nouveau film,
on a toujours de nouveaux problèmes.
Oui, il fallait que ça arrive tu vois !
Alors, je n'étais pas tout seul
à la réalisation d’un effet spécial.
On était des grosses équipes,
regroupées en plusieurs spécialités.
Il y a ceux qui modèlent,
ceux qui animent, ceux qui simulent,
ceux qui éclairent, ceux
qui peignent, et j’en passe.
Pour réaliser un plan, il faut de grosses
équipes, organisées, hiérarchisées.
Moi, j’ai pour spécialité
ce qu’on appelle le « compositing ».
Le compositing, c’est l’art d’assembler
les différentes couches d’effets.
J’ai à ma disposition les images
filmées par la caméra,
je retire les fonds verts
et bleus s'il y en a,
et j’intègre les faux décors, les effets,
et les créatures qu’auront
éclairé et animé mes collègues.
Et puis, j'ajoute aussi des éléments
venant de vidéos,
de photos, de décors peints.
Bref, c’est un peu de la bidouille.
Mais, j’ai la responsabilité
de l’intégration des images de synthèse.
Et ça parfois, c’est
une grosse responsabilité.
Je pourrais dire que mon travail
se scinde en deux parties.
Il y a la première partie où je découvre
les éléments à ma disposition.
Je vais commencer
à les composer entres eux,
et je vais voir
ce que je peux faire avec.
Je ne cherche pas encore
à rendre les choses réalistes,
je cherche plutôt à créer une esquisse,
quelque chose qui va me donner
la direction dans laquelle je vais aller,
le rythme, le storytelling,
la composition du plan...
Alors tout ça, c’est marrant,
ça me fait penser
à quand j’étais gamin, à Noël,
et que j’attendais une nouvelle
boîte de Lego sous le sapin.
Je courrais encore en pyjamas
genre « Ouais; trop bien, des Lego ! »
Là, c’est la même chose,
j’ai un certain nombre de pièces,
et je crée un univers fantastique avec.
Des fois, je vais même
au boulot en pyjamas.
(Rires)
Ensuite, il y a
la deuxième partie du travail
qui consiste à intégrer
tous ces éléments ensemble,
les rendre réels, leur donner vie.
Et alors, avant de vous expliquer
un peu plus comment j’opère,
j’aimerais qu’on marque une pause
et que chacun observe autour de lui,
ce qui rend notre univers
visuellement réel,
uniquement à l’aide de vos yeux.
Ce n’est pas facile.
Par exemple, vous me voyez là,
sur scène, devant vous.
Quels sont les éléments
qu’on peut prendre en compte ?
Il y a la lumière qui m’éclaire
de façon à éclairer aussi le décor.
Il y a la couleur, la chaleur
de cette lumière, sa direction,
les ombres qu’elle génère.
Après, il y a moi, la texture
de mes vêtements,
la texture de ma peau,
la perfection de la Nature...
(Rires)
Et puis, il y a les détails,
la perspective.
Par exemple, ceux qui sont
assis au dernier rang
ne me perçoivent pas de la même façon
que ceux assis au premier rang.
Au premier rang, je suis sûr
que vous êtes capable de voir
les poils que mon chat,
Abribus, a laissé sur mon t-shirt...
(Rires)
... alors que vous au dernier rang n’avez
même pas remarqué que j’étais mal rasé.
En fait, à l'époque, j’ai filé
une photo à l’organisation,
et j'ai essayé de ressembler
au type de la photo,
parce que j’avais, quand
même, une sacrée moustache !
Bon, bref.
Alors, tous ces détails, au poil près,
permettent à notre cerveau
de conclure que cet instant est réel,
car il peut faire référence à d’autres
événements similaires qu’il a déjà vécus.
Pour qu’un trucage marche,
il faut appliquer ces mêmes règles,
tirer ces règles du réel
et les appliquer à l’irréel
afin que le spectateur se dise :
« Oui, ça marche,
c’est comme dans la vraie vie. »
Et il en va de même
avec les créatures fantastiques
et les mondes fantastiques aussi.
Il est important de tirer
nos observations du réel,
même si nous n’avons jamais vu
en vrai le Chat Poté ou les Minions.
Au-delà de la direction
artistique du film,
il faut tirer nos observations du réel
et les appliquer à l’irréel
afin de créer cette métaphore sensorielle
pour que le cerveau du spectateur
accepte de coopérer avec les images.
Quels sont ces
éléments d’observations ?
Est-ce que c’est la lumière ?
Est-ce que c’est le poil ?
il y en a encore un ici…
Eh bien, je n’ai pas
de réponse toute faite.
À chaque nouveau plan et nouveau film,
on a de nouvelles problématiques,
parfois faciles, parfois difficiles.
Ce qui est sûr, c’est qu’à chaque fois,
je dois expérimenter,
tenter de nouvelles approches,
et parfois ça fonctionne, et parfois non.
Alors, j’aimerais vous donner
un exemple concret.
En 2013, je travaillais sur Godzilla.
Nous avions des consignes
de direction artistique très précises.
Par exemple, il fallait représenter
au mieux la notion de taille du monstre.
Il est grand, Godzilla,
ce n’est pas nouveau.
Il devait être gigantesque,
plus grand qu’un gratte-ciel.
Pour ça, Godzilla ne devait jamais
apparaître en entier à l’image.
Il était toujours à moitié
caché par des buildings,
ou submergé par de l’eau,
ou derrière des couches
de brouillard et de brume,
ce qui m’amène à une deuxième
direction artistique importante,
c’était la présence d’énormément
de pluie, de fumée, de feu, de brouillard.
Tous ces éléments devaient se mélanger
pour mettre en valeur les créatures,
et renforcer l’aspect chaotique
et mystique du film.
Ça voulait dire qu’il y avait une tonne
d’éléments à intégrer et c’était dur,
mais il fallait vraiment
qu’on arrive à tous les intégrer
pour que le spectateur se dise :
« Je sais que Godzilla
n’existe pas, mais là, j’y crois.
Je n'ai même pas besoin
du petit verre de gnôle, c'est bon. »
(Rires)
Je vais être franc avec vous,
sur ce film, j’ai vraiment galéré.
C’était super dur
et je me souviendrai toujours
du temps qu’il m’a fallu
pour comprendre
comment représenter cette impression
de distance et de profondeur
à travers différents éléments
de brume, de brouillard, de feu, etc.
J’avais mon esquisse, j’avais réussi
à superposer tous mes éléments
mais je n'arrivais pas à leur donner vie.
Tout était là, mais ça ne marchait pas.
J’avais l’aide de mes superviseurs
et de mes collègues
qui me donnaient leurs avis,
qui me permettait d’avancer pas à pas.
Malgré tout, l’intégration
était trop visible, ça ne marchait pas.
Un soir, je suis sorti
du bureau assez tard,
après un énième refus
de mon travail par ma supervision.
Il était passé minuit -
des fois travailler
dans les effets spéciaux,
c’est aussi être invisible
pour sa famille et ses amis
en période de fin de projet -
bref, je suis sorti du studio à minuit,
j’ai enfourché mon vélo
pour rentrer chez moi.
J’aimais faire du vélo à ce moment
de l’année, à Vancouver, au Canada,
car c’était l’automne ;
et juste avant l’hiver,
il y a cette espèce de brume épaisse
qui se forme dans les rues,
et ça leur donne un aspect très étrange.
La brume dans les rues,
ça n’a rien à voir avec le fait
qu’ils viennent de légaliser
le cannabis au Canada,
c’est purement météorologique !
Donc, je pédalais à fond parce que
j’avais envie d’aller vite me coucher,
il était tard, mais aussi parce que
j’avais besoin d’évacuer ma frustration.
Franchement quand tu fais
des plans, des plans,
des versions, et des itérations
de la même chose,
sans aucun succès,
ça devient extrêmement frustrant,
et on commence à se remettre en question :
est-ce que je suis fait pour ce métier ?
Cette nuit-là, je me suis vraiment
mis à râler contre moi.
J'hurlais dans la rue : « T'es qu’un nul !
Change de métier, t’as aucun talent !
Tu ferais mieux de faire
un truc plus calme,
genre gérer un petit Airbnb
sur la plage, genre oklm quoi »
(Rires)
J'étais sur le pont de Burrard -
pour ceux qui connaissent Vancouver -
et j’avais laissé derrière
moi le centre-ville.
Je me suis rendu compte que j’avais
oublié d’allumer les lumières de mon vélo.
Alors, au-delà du fait que c’est
une prune assez élevée au Canada,
ce n'était pas forcement
très « safe » aussi...
vu la visibilité.
Du coup, je me suis arrêté sur
le côté, pour allumer les lumières.
J'ai tourné la tête,
et là j’ai vu, au loin,
une vue hallucinante :
le centre-ville était baigné
dans un épais brouillard,
et on voyait les toits des gratte-ciels
qui disparaissaient dans la brume,
les rendant encore plus haut.
Et puis, il y avait toutes
les lumières de la ville
qui diffusaient des halos
colorés dans le brouillard.
Et puis, il y avait cette usine devant moi
qui crachait une grosse fumée
blanche épaisse
qui absorbait les lumières
des néons et qui les rediffusait.
On pouvait sentir la profondeur
dans l’atmosphère,
sentir la profondeur dans le brouillard.
Seulement certains détails
apparaissaient par-ci, par-là.
J’étais là, halluciné.
J’étais dans le film !
C’est-à-dire qu’à ce moment précis,
la vie réelle suivait la même
direction artistique
que la séquence du film
sur laquelle je travaillais.
Alors, j’ai observé
tout ce que je pouvais ;
je ne voulais vraiment pas
en manquer un morceau,
des subtiles variations
de la couleur du ciel,
aux infimes particules
de brume devant moi.
C’était magique !
C’était comme si mon sens
de la vue était décuplé.
Je percevais, à ce moment-là,
quelque chose qui avait toujours
été invisible pour moi.
Ce soir-là, j'ai trouvé
la solution à mon problème.
Le lendemain, je suis arrivé
au bureau, et en quelques heures,
j’ai fait les modifications
à apporter à mon plan,
et mon travail a été approuvé
par mes superviseurs.
Mon dur labeur était devenu invisible.
Alors, j’ai envie de vous montrer
quelques-uns de ces plans
que j’ai réalisés à ce moment-là.
Je n’ai pas mis de son,
parce qu'on est sur le visuel.
Et je vous rejoins juste après.
Alors,
certains me diront :
« Mon pote, il suffisait
de regarder, tu vois. »
(Rires)
Certes, la réalité m’avait aidé
à réaliser mon trucage,
mais c’est, avant tout, la persévérance
et l’exploration de l’image
qui m’ont aidé à être plus curieux,
plus sensible au monde qui m’entoure.
Alors, cette histoire
que je viens de vous raconter,
ce n’est pas un cas isolé.
Je l’ai vécue plusieurs fois
et je continue à la vivre.
À chaque nouveau film,
il y a ce petit truc qui se passe.
Certains appelleront ça une
« déformation professionnelle »,
moi j’appelle ça mes
« moments de clairvoyance geek ».
Alors par exemple, sur Deadpool 2,
j’étais obnubilé par le feu
parce que je travaillais sur les mains
enflammées du gamin Rusty.
Sur Pokemon, je travaillais
sur la séquence de la forêt,
donc c’était comment la lumière
se déplace à travers les feuilles.
Ça affecte, ça affecte vraiment.
Quand j’étais chez Dreamworks,
c’était des créatures poilues,
donc, du coup, c’était
les poils, encore une fois !
Et pour vous dire à quel point
ça affecte, là en ce moment,
je travaille sur un crash d’avion.
Je peux vous dire, prendre l’avion
pour venir ici, c'était en mode bonjour.
J'ai récupéré quelques bonnes
références visuelles,
(En riant) c'était bien.
Atteindre ce moment de clairvoyance
qui permet de déceler ce petit détail
qui va transformer un travail artistique,
demande du temps.
Toutes ces itérations,
ces versions, sont nécessaires.
Elles me permettent de définir
dans un premier temps
ce qui va être techniquement
et artistiquement possible.
Les versions que je présentais
à mes superviseurs
n’étaient pas forcément déplorables,
mais elles ne fonctionnaient pas
dans un contexte donné,
comme le contexte du film, par exemple.
Chaque refus d’une version me
permettait d’éliminer une voie sans issue,
mais aussi de garder
les éléments importants.
Et de fil en aiguille, on arrive
à mettre les choses en place.
Afin de percevoir la solution finale,
il est important de mettre
de l’ordre dans le chaos initial.
Et puis alors, ça y est, on peut voir
enfin ce qui manque :
un petit reflet de réalisme
dans les yeux d’un personnage,
l’ajustement de certains éléments
permettant de mieux retranscrire l’espace,
ou la correction des couleurs
pour une meilleure cohérence visuelle.
Quand tous ces petits détails
ont été ajoutés un à un et ajustés,
alors naît ce sentiment d’accomplissement,
et c’est tout ça, le processus créatif.
Ed Catmull, le fondateur
de Pixar, disait à ce propos :
« L'échec n’est pas un mal nécessaire.
En fait, ce n’est pas un mal du tout.
C’est une conséquence nécessaire
de l’accomplissement
de quelque chose de nouveau. »
Cette citation a beaucoup
d’importance pour moi,
parce qu’il m’a fallu
du temps pour comprendre
que mes erreurs, mes échecs,
n’étaient pas un mal,
mais qu’elles étaient nécessaires
à ce processus créatif.
Il m’a fallu du temps pour ne plus
avoir honte de tenter et d’échouer,
et simplement d’essayer.
Il m’a fallu du temps pour
comprendre qu’il fallait du temps.
Il m’a fallu du temps
pour comprendre que travailler,
ça ne voulait pas
toujours dire réussir,
que le chemin qui mène à la réussite
n’est pas toujours linéaire.
Et je dirais même que travailler,
ça ne veut pas toujours dire
que l’on sait ce que l’on fait.
Pour moi, l’expérience, je la redéfinis.
À chaque nouveau projet,
je redéfinis ce processus créatif,
je me l’approprie un peu plus.
Et puis je cherche toujours
à aller plus loin.
Mais pour moi la vraie expérience,
c’est l’acceptation
de ce processus créatif
inévitable à toute création.
Il m’aura fallu du temps
pour me rendre compte
que pour être un artiste de l’invisible,
il me fallait d’abord être capable
de percevoir l’invisible.
S’il y a une chose que je peux tirer
de mon expérience aujourd’hui,
c’est qu'à chaque fois qu’on fait face
à un problème gros comme Godzilla,
à chaque fois qu’on échoue,
il ne faut pas renoncer.
Il faut garder la conviction
que toute étape est
nécessaire à l’accomplissement,
et qu'on commence seulement
à distinguer l’invisible.
Je vous remercie.
(Applaudissements)